en 1998 trek smith un pilote de ligne
repères en survolant le plateau de fini
springs en australie un dessin immense
sur le sol un géoglyphes un homme nu qui
tend un bâton alors géoglyphes
préhistorique oublier des archéologues
oeuvre extraterrestre non c'est tout
simplement le délire d'un artiste
australien s'ils doutent a pu subsister
pas longtemps les spécialistes ne s'y
sont pas trompés c'est que cette image
est fortement inspiré de représentation
très commune chez les peuples
préhistorique un homme nu tenant une
arme
rien de plus commun en réalité pourtant
il fut une époque où il était tout
simplement inenvisageable de dessiner ça
du moins ça tout seul bonjour à tous
bienvenue au vortex
après l'alimentation la guerre qui sont
des activités tout aussi essentielle à
la vie humaine
il reste un domaine à explorer pour
cette série révolutionnaire celui de
l'art en commençant avec une question
toute simple depuis quand l'humain se
représente il
car si nous sommes aujourd'hui
complètement familiariser à qui des deux
se montrer au monde entier à grand
renfort de selphy notre bouille n'a pas
toujours été au centre de l'attention au
paléolithique le choix entre un modèle
de mammouth est celui d'une kim
kardashian pour décorer le nec plus
ultra des grottes été vite fait la
grosse bestiole à poils longs l'emporter
question de goût
alors à quand remontent les premières
représentations humaines dans la grotte
de chauvet
on connait une figures anthropomorphes
daté d'il ya trente trois mille ans d'un
couple d'humains à tête de bison plus
tard à lascaux il ya dix-huit mille ans
un homme ithyphalliques ça veut dire
qu'il a le sexe en érection est placé en
position allongée avec plusieurs animaux
autour de lui alors pourquoi on l'a
représenté comme ça on peut rien
affirmer mais plutôt que d'y voir un
fantasme au fil d'un assouvie il s'agit
peut être juste d'un homme en train de
rêver on se rend rapidement compte que
ce qui est important dans l'art pour les
périodes des plus anciennes ce sont les
animaux pas ou peu d'humains pendant des
millénaires et bam lorsque l'agriculture
est adopté on assiste à une explosion de
figures humaines et de nouveaux symboles
en quelques millénaires on va passer de
100 à ça vous y voyez une régression
c'est vrai il ya moins de détails les
formes sont réduites à de simples traits
les aurochs et rhinocéros laineux ont
disparu mais pourquoi est on passé en
seulement quelques millénaires de la
fresque majestueuse du règne animal au
bonhomme d'atouts si nous sommes passés
de ça à ça ce n'est pas parce que nous
avons perdu soudainement 52 cuit et
parce qu'au moment où nous changions de
mode de production avec l'agriculture
nous adoptions aussi un nouveau système
de représentation un système de symbole
on appelle ça la reposte paléolithique
schématique vous embêtez pas avec ce
terme
ce qu'il faut retenir c'est que cet art
se distingue par un recours aux signes à
la schématisation là où l'art
paléolithique représentait un bestiaire
de manière naturaliste avec des
attributs précis et des positions
étudier les animaux étaient les stars
des grottes dessinée en grand avec un
réel sens esthétique
le basculement dans le néolithique c'est
donc l'avènement du symbole les figures
représentés sont plus nombreuses et plus
rapidement exécutées les animaux
deviennent et graphiquement plus vagues
parfois réduits à leur seul caractère de
quadrupèdes tout ça coïncide avec la
présence des figures humaines elle aussi
schématiser mais dont les
représentations de vienne centrale dans
les compositions artistiques
on a déjà dit comment avec le
néolithique l'humain occuper une place
nouvelle dans le règne animal celui de
producteur et non plus de prédateurs
ce qu'on observe dans l'art c'est la
traduction symbolique de ce nouvel
esprit révolutionnaire
ce n'est plus un au rock aux pattes
gracile et aux babines retroussées qui
occupe le centre des tableaux mais un
groupe d'humains qui danse et qui chasse
l'animal n'est plus qu'un accessoire
dans cette nouvelle histoire
issa en sommes faits voler la vedette
bon vous avez compris le principe mais
ce serait assez réducteur de tout
généralisée de cette manière faut pas
croire que les humains du paléolithique
n'avait aucun symbole il y à quelques
motifs qui acquièrent une valeur de
symbole très ponctuation animaux évoqué
par un caractère comme par exemple une
simple conte pour dessiner le dos d'un
mammouth
il ya aussi les idées des numérations de
mains négatives etc etc
ensuite faut pas sous-estimer le fait
que beaucoup d'oeuvres se sont
détériorées pour l'ehpad des plus
anciennes et fresques en plein air au
bout d'un moment c'est face tout
simplement
alors que celles des grottes se
conservent mieux ce qu'on peut quand
même rappeler c'est que l'art des
cavernes est sans doute lié à des
rituels initiatiques
il fallait ramper dans le noir sur des
centaines de mètres à rouffignac par
exemple pour admirer les peintures du
fond de la grotte
ses oeuvres sont donc investi d'un
caractère exceptionnel au moins par leur
localisation 7
loin des habitations dans des lieux
teintés de surnaturel
ce que ne semble plus être dans la
grande majorité des cas la reposte
agriculture qui s'affiche à l'extérieur
mais dont nous allons perdu les codes
pour la décrypter l'interprétation des
symboles en archéologie d'ailleurs un
jeu risqué pour ne pas dire quasi
impossible cette limite de la
connaissance de la reconnaissance est
d'ailleurs une porte d'entrée à toutes
les théories les plus farfelues à base
de culte solaire lunaire de déesse mère
et de chamanisme
le fait est qu'on n'en sait rien et
qu'on ne sera jamais en mesure de
prouver quoi que ce soit concernant les
croyances de nos ancêtres préhistoriques
et après tous ces signes n'étaient
peut-être pas faites pour être
intelligible aux yeux de tous on connaît
l'exemple des dogon qui gardent secret
une partie de leurs symboles et ne les
dévoile qu'à certains moments de la vie
il ya seulement certains membres de la
société pendant des cérémonies rituelles
de notre côté en occident nous sommes
sans cesse confrontés à des signes que
nous ne comprenons pas toujours c'est le
cas des graffitis nos villes
pratiquement illisible pour les non
initiés mais nous en faisons également
l'expérience avec internet qui a son
propre langage
alors je vais pas m'aventurer dans une
explication du code informatique et du
langage internet c'est vraiment pas
souhaitable heureusement j'ai la chance
d'avoir des colloques qui s'y
connaissent sur le sujet
j'ai besoin de vous parce que je suis en
train de faire un épisode là où je parle
des symboles des premiers symboles que
les humains ont inventé pour communiquer
représenter leur vif
on sait pas trop justement jusqu'à quel
point les symboles c'est pratique pour
l'utilisateur l'arobase par exemple
c'est un vieux sigles qu'on utilisait
déjà pendant la renaissance servait à
signifier l'appartenance genre pour dire
des pommes à 12 dollars le kilo ben on
était un petit apte à la place de ce que
tu peux juste m'expliquer ce qu'est un
même en commande depuis quand c'est glee
c'est quoi l'idée un peu populaire du
tout et qu'un homme se serait juste une
image sur lequel on accole du texte pour
signifier une émotion au final le terme
vient de richard dawkins on peut voir le
même juste comme un fragment
d'information en fait le même en fait
c'est un élément de culture qui se
transmet d'un individu à un autre par
imitation tu m'as parlé un jour de
l'unicode l'unicode c'est juste un
standard qui a été créé pour pouvoir
unifier un peu tous les textes sur
internet et sur les logiciels en fait à
travers le monde bon paquet de problèmes
de compatibilité entre les différents
logiciels faisant par un document au
japon sera toujours lisibles sur un pc
en rond gris tu vois ouais c'est fait
pour être compris par tous le plus
longtemps plus voilà donc les
archéologues on se retrouve avec des
signes on interprète avec nos valeurs à
nous mais on n'est sûr de rien et on
n'arrive pas à les lire et donc moi je
me demande tu vois dans dans quelques
siècles tous ces symboles qu'on a sur
internet qui est vraiment l'endroit où
on écrit et on laisse notre histoire
quoi est ce qu'on sera encore capable de
comprendre et peut-être qu'on m'a
complètement bourré écoutez merci
beaucoup
tout comme les codes informatiques
oriente les utilisateurs l'une des
fonctions dollar symbolique
préhistorique est aussi de localiser
entre les parois chargée de symboles et
placés sur des axes de passage les
dolmens et menhirs visible de loin les
sociétés agro pastoral on parlera
restructurer le paysage elles se sont
approprié les lieux remarquables pour
graver et peindre leurs motifs de telle
sorte que la valise l'espace comprendre
les symboles et les productions
artistiques dans leur diversité
c'est essayer de comprendre les bases de
la création mythologique de la société
qui les a produits
cette identité culturelle que nous
aimerions approché se heurte
malheureusement aux limites de
l'archéologie les gestes la parole le
système de pensée nos ancêtres tout ce
qui ne laisse pas de traces nous est
confisqué il a par les scènes de chasse
nous sommes la plupart du temps devant
des oeuvres pratiquement inintelligible
on peut pas savoir dans quels contextes
culturels
elles ont été réalisées si les hommes
ont peu à peu désiré se représenter
c'est peut-être parce que le prestige
social étaient devenus le principal
moteur de la société
nous représentions des animaux car il
constitue l essentiel de notre
imaginaire peut-être qu'il était même
considéré comme des alter ego dès que
les humains se lance dans la
domestication c'est que leur regard a
changé
l'animal n'est plus tout à fait un sujet
ils glissent vers statut d'objet
d'outils de richesse au service de son
possesseur et les échanges économiques
ou la notoriété prennent le pas sur la
mythologie
c'est ce qu'on observe dans l'art
préhistorique durant ces 3 épisodes on a
vu comment l'agriculture a généré des
stocks qu'il a fallu gérer
économiquement mais aussi socialement
résultat cette richesse matérielle a
permis une certaine classe dirigeante
d'émerger et de faire valoir son pouvoir
par l'appropriation des armes mais aussi
par le contrôle de son image
pour finir je ne peux que vous
conseiller de vous méfier du terme de
révolution plus qu'un événement brutal
et sans précédent qui ferait
radicalement changé les sociétés dans
une voie totalement nouvelle il faut
plutôt y voir une accélération de
mécanismes existants la métallurgie n'a
pas inventé le commerce
elle a en revanche considérablement
contribué à ce que nous en savons en
stimuler les réseaux le néolithique n'a
pas constitué le début des
représentations humaines pour
l'apparition des relations pouvoir
pourtant ces deux phénomènes explose à
cette période
les inventions techniques n'ont pas
forcément eu le rôle déterminant qu'on
leur donne sur les changements des
sociétés on se focalise beaucoup là
dessus parce qu'on vit une période de
grands bouleversements technologiques
mais c'est probablement un biais de
réflexion d'autant qu'en préhistoire on
n'a que ça à se mettre sous la dent et
on a vite fait de croire que parce qu'on
se met à trouver du cuivre
les sociétés changent ou pourrait aussi
dire que c'est le contraire la
métallurgie apparaît parce que la
société est prête ou bien de manière
plus raisonnable que les deux chevauche
la nouveauté découle du changement des
mentalités autant qu'elle l'a fondée
j'en ai terminé avec cette série
j'espère qu'elle vous a plu en tout cas
c'est pas fini parce qu'on se retrouve
la semaine prochaine ici à la même heure
sur youtube aura un live avec un invité
surprise un spécialiste qui pourra
répondre à toutes les questions que vous
posez
autour de ce thème abonnez vous laisser
un pouce bleus et je vous dis à la
prochaine salut
[Musique]